drake definitely has some time for the
haters uh specifically his internet
trolls coming for his kit
oh this is so good so drake got into a
little bit of a heated debate on
instagram over nba star john marant's
dad who has been criticized for his
intense support of his son from the
sidelines
yeah so drake defended john's dad
suggesting he would express the same
enthusiasm if his son adonis is
competing in well anything commenting on
an instagram post drake wrote imagine
your son makes the league and he's jaw
or melo or lonzo all you can do is be
elated and competitive and over
supportive and it's a rite of passage to
that the og's talk
i know i'ma be this way even if my son
is in a rubik's cube competition
one user replied to the rapper by poking
fun at his alleged past use of ghost
riders saying yasun probably play with
ghost riders
and here's where it gets good of course
drake didn't let that one
slide and piped back i just followed
your girl because she's probably
miserable and needs some excitement in
her life
as it turns out drake did indeed find
his wife on instagram followed her and
even slid into her dms saying i'm here
for you ma more or less story don't mess
with drake because he will go for your
significant other
i'm dead deceased i love this story
yeah oh this is super spicy listen you
go after someone's kid in any way even
reference someone's kid in a negative
way
it's grounds to
say something crazy back at them
and i really appreciate the fact that he
didn't say anything crazy he didn't
ignore him he he spoke on it but he made
it funny he made it spicy and he went
around that like you know he went for
the wife and then the best part about it
is the girl was like hype
she was our stories like
she was hyped so i know he's that guy is
just
it was just i fully agree with you i
love that he didn't turn this into like
another
you know negative sort of um you know
beef with someone on instagram and it's
like so nice to see that he kind of like
had fun with it and
you know got to play but i mean is this
like is this do i need to get
like my signature to like sign up on
instagram and come after drake is this
how i get him in my dms oh
oh is that is that what we're doing okay
so that is a wow so that's an avenue now
for people
um i have a feeling that it's probably
an avenue now yeah
interesting new development okay
interesting um ladies i don't know if
you want that type of energy but go
crazy i don't think you want your
husband to get into beef
doesn't look it's not doesn't seem